AND THE REFUSAL TO GIVE PEACE A
CHANCE.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
REMEMBER WHEN THE LEFT WAS ALL
ABOUT LOVE, PEACE, AND
UNDERSTANDING?
>> ♪♪ ALL WE ARE SAYING IS GIVE
PEACE A CHANCE ♪
♪    ♪♪
>> Laura: YOU REMEMBER THOSE
GREAT MUSICAL NUMBERS AT THOSE
NO NUKES CONCERT IN THE LATE
'70s, EARLY '80s, JACKSON
BROWN.
THE LEFT THOUGHT WE SHOULD STOP
BEING SO BELLIGERENT TOWARDS THE
SOVIET UNION, WE SHOULD ENGAGE
WITH THE SOVIETS ALL FOR A
BETTER WORLD.
SOME EVEN ADMIRED THE CASTROS IN
CUBA AND THEY FORWARD WITH
MARXIST IDEOLOGY HERE AT HOME.
SO ONE WOULD'VE THOUGHT THAT
MANY OF THE SAME PEOPLE AND
THEIR IDEOLOGICAL OFFSPRING WILL
VIEW PRESIDENT TRUMP'S SUMMIT
WITH KIM JONG UN AS A MOMENT TO
SAVOR, A REAL CHANCE TO CREATE A
MORE PEACEFUL PLANET.
BUT NO.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
BECAUSE THE MAN IS DOING THE
OUTREACH IN NEGOTIATING IS
DONALD J. TRUMP.
BEFORE, DURING, AND AFTER HIS
WHIRLWIND TRIP TO SINGAPORE FOR
THE KIM MEETING COME HIS CRITICS
AND BOTH PARTIES KEPT REVEALING
THEMSELVES.
THEIR NARRATIVES KEPT SHIFTING.
SIX MONTHS AGO, IT WAS THIS: :
>> A LACK OF STRATEGY IN MY VIEW
HAS ASKED SLIDING TOWARD WAR BY
NEXT SUMMER.
>> TRUMP'S COMMENTS ABOUT
NUCLEAR WEAPONS HAVE EXPERTS
WORRY HE COULD LITERALLY
INADVERTENTLY TRIGGER A
CATASTROPHE.
>> HAS RECKLESS BEHAVIOR COULD
LAUNCH THE NATION ON THE PATH
WORLD WAR III.
>> Laura: YOU ARE ALL WRONG.
EVERYONE OF YOU.
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TIME TO
LIST YOU ALL, YOU ARE WRONG.
BUT THEY TEAR ANY OF BEING
WRONGED BY THE EXPERTS IS
NOTHING NEW.
BUT THEY WERE WRONG ABOUT THE
ELECTION OF DONALD TRUMP, THE
ECONOMY OF DONALD TRUMP, THE
PRO-LIFE COMMITMENT OF
DONALD TRUMP, AND THE TRADE
POLICIES OF DONALD TRUMP, JUST
TO NAME A FEW.
NATURALLY, AS THEY SUMMIT BEGAN,
THE ERROR CAUCUS OFFERED THIS
TRENCHANT ANALYSIS.
>> DONALD TRUMP CAN RELATE TO
AUTHORITARIANS.
AS A FORMER BUSINESSMAN, HE
LIKES ABSOLUTE CONTROL.
>> IS HE A WANNABE DESPERATE?
>> I'VE CONCEDED THAT FOR YEARS.
>> THE MARKED WHERE -- MORE WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT NORTH KOREA,
THE LESS WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
RUSSIA.
>> THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT
FOREIGN POLICY.
IT IS ABOUT DONALD TRUMP --
>> Laura: THAT'S ALL THEY'VE
GOT, SAYS THE WOMAN WHO BROUGHT
US THE WINNING CAMPAIGN OF
JOHN McCAIN IN 2008?
OH, OKAY.
RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT,
THRIVING ECONOMY, TAX CUTS,
DESTRUCTION OF ISIS AND A
FOREIGN POLICY COUP IS ALL
THEY'VE GOT.
EVEN AFTER TRUMP BROUGHT KIM TO
SINGAPORE, EVEN AFTER HE
SQUEEZED CONCESSIONS AND AT
LEAST A COMMITMENT TO
DENUCLEARIZE THE KOREAN
PENINSULA, THE LEFT STILL WILL
NOT GIVE HIM A SHRED OF CREDIT.
>> DONALD TRUMP, THE REAL ESTATE
DEVELOPER.
AND HE DOESN'T REALIZE THAT THIS
DICTATOR DOESN'T WANT BEACH
CONDOS.
HE WANTS NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
>> EMPTY WORDS FROM A
POTENTIALLY WORDS.
FLAGS AND CEREMONY.
DOESN'T NECESSARILY NEED TO THE
CONSEQUENCES THAT WE HOPED FOR.
>> ARE WE GOING TO HEAD WITH
HOPEFUL WISHFUL THOUGHTS?
I FIND IT INCREDIBLY WORRYING
AND DEPRESSING.
>> NO KNOWLEDGE OF HISTORY.
IT IS STAGGERING TO REALIZE HOW
ON SELF-AWARE AND THE LACK OF
KNOWLEDGE.
>> Laura: THE LACK OF
I DON'T RECALL MOST OF THESE
MEDIA ELITES GRIPING ABOUT
EMBRACING DICTATORS WHEN
BARACK OBAMA RESTORED TIES WITH
THE CASTROS IN CUBA OR WHEN HE
GAVE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO THE DICTATORS IN
IRAN.
BOGUS DENUCLEARIZATION DEAL.
WHEN HE HELD A STEAK DINNER FOR
THE CHINESE DICTATOR.
THE SELECTIVE MORAL OUTRAGE HERE
IS GALLING, PREDICTABLE, AND SO
BLATANT.
WHEN TRUMP TALKS TOUGH, THEY SAY
HE IS A WARMONGER TAKING US TO
WAR.
BUT WHEN HE GETS DOWN GUYS TO
SIT AT THE NEGOTIATING TABLE AND
BEGIN TO HAMMER OUT A PIECE
FRAMEWORK, HE IS SAVAGE FOR
EMBRACING A DICTATOR.
WHICH IS IT?
THEY BEAT HIM UP FOR SAYING HE
MAKE A CHANGE.
BUT TRUMP HIMSELF SAID, LISTEN
CAREFULLY, HE COULD BE WRONG.
>> I THINK HONESTLY I THINK HE'S
GOING TO DO THESE THINGS.
I MAY BE WRONG.
>> Laura: HE SET ALL HAVE TO
COME BACK AND APOLOGIZE.
I WOULD LIKE IT.
EVEN WITH THE HIGH-STAKES
INVOLVED, REALLY SERIOUS,
POSSIBLY DEADLY CONSEQUENCES OF
FAILURE, PRESIDENT TRUMP MAKES
GEOPOLITICS FUN AGAIN.
>> I MAY STAND BEFORE YOU IN SIX
MONTHS AND SAY HEY, I WAS WRONG.
I DON'T KNOW THAT I WILL EVER
ADMIT THAT BUT I WILL FIND SOME
KIND OF EXCUSE.
>> Laura: THE DOUBTERS HAD TO
LAUGH A LITTLE.
HAVE SOME FUN.
IT'S A GREAT TIME TO BE AN
AMERICAN.
LIKE, WHO ELSE COULD HAVE GOTTEN
US TO THIS POINT?
>> HE SAID OPENLY TO A COUPLE
REPORTERS WITH HIM THAT HE KNOWS
NO OTHER PRESIDENT EVER COULD
HAVE DONE THIS.
>> Laura: WELL, OKAY, SO HE'S
GOT A BIG EGO.
WHAT PRESIDENT DOESN'T?
BIG DEAL.
ISN'T TRUMP'S PATH BETTER THAN
THE ALTERNATIVE THE ELITES WERE
WARNING US ABOUT SIX MONTHS AGO?
A NORTH KOREA THAT IS SO
ISOLATED IT MIGHT THINK TO DO
THE UNTHINKABLE, HIT AN AMERICAN
CITY WITH AN ICBM?
I SAY LET HIM DISTRACT US ALL,
LET THEM KEEP GOING SLAPPING
THEIR LIPS, LET THEM LIE AND
CONTRADICT THEIR OWN ANALYSES.
WHILE THEIR AUDIENCE AND
READERSHIP SHRINKS AND THEY DO
IN OUT, MORE AMERICANS I THINK
ARE SEEN THROUGH THE MEDIA
MANIPULATION.
TRUMP, AT HOME AND ABROAD, IS